My question is to the minister for defence,
can the minister confirm whether he has taken
his golf clubs with him on any Defence
VIP special purpose aircraft flights, and if so,
on how many flights?
Well, thank you,
Mister Speaker,
and can I thank the member for his question?
Uh, let me be very clear.
Every place I have been,
everything I have done,
has been in pursuit of my duties as the, uh,
Deputy Prime Minister and the minister for defence
on behalf of this country.
And I stand absolutely
by every flight I have ever taken
on the special purpose aircraft,
or for that matter,
any flight that I have taken commercially.
Back to relevance,
Mister Speaker,
the question was very specific
whether or not the minister had taken the clubs.
Now, the fact that this is in the public domain
is because this government released information
about the use of the special purpose aircraft.
Because as the now minister for defence,
my office has logged
numerous requests from the leader of the opposition
about him going on special purpose aircraft,
including in the last six weeks,
two times, at least in writing,
to go to a game at the Matildas. Order!
Order!